what up space fame goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss another hype demonstrator topic
today i wanted to specifically take a
look at tundra's dad one of the most
interesting and underrated characters in
the series so make sure to stay tuned
for that if you do enjoy these
demonstrator videos i want to keep them
coming you know what to do tell the
demons there within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is strongest
demonstrator energy and passing is
scared moves on energy so choose wisely
if you haven't make this video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
including juicy updates about new
seasons and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all we
get a lot of information about tundra's
dad during a flashback that takes place
while tanjuro and giu are fighting akaza
that memory is tied to tundra gaining
full access to the transparent world and
the selfless state a state that allows
him to completely outclass upper moon 3
akaza if only temporarily thus since he
learned this from his dad it's already
implied that his dad was a beast however
up to this point we didn't see his dad
actually fight someone or something sure
he could dance throughout the night
without getting tired even though he was
sick which is very impressive but we
didn't actually see if he could
translate that into combat skills in
this flashback though we will see
exactly that akasa once beat by selfless
state tanjuro will say it was like he
was fighting a plant and this flashback
starts with tundra saying his father was
like a plant so if anyone's compared to
a plant and demonstrator you know it's
because they're open when tundra
compares his father to a plant the
implication is that he learned to
maintain this selfless state which akasa
called the domain of supremacy aka the
pinnacle of martial arts that akasa had
been seeking his whole life yurichi the
strongest demonstrator in history was
similar to this too and we're going to
see over the course of this video that
tundra's father actually had much more
in common with the strongest
demonstrating history than tundra did
suggesting he was even more fit to be
the chosen one than tanjiru but we'll
get into the specifics of that later
like yorichi tunjur describes his dad as
not being temperamental at all and
always calm having that stoic thing
going on is definitely something that is
associated with supreme strength in this
series even when tenjiro's dad got sick
before he died he was the same still
calm right to the end when tundra thinks
of his dad he remembers his gentle smile
and calm voice like the streamlet of the
river just as with the selfless state
tundra's that is being associated with
nature here like he's part of it not
separate from it that goes into buddhist
philosophy and in demon slayer it's
definitely a sign of someone being very
strong we then get into the hinokami
kagura aka the dance of the fire god kid
tanjuro asked his dad who's called
tanjuro what tundra was thinking of as
he danced it's explained that the kamado
house performed that dance at the
beginning of every year for generations
it was demanding lasting from sunset to
sunrise there are 12 routines performed
before sunrise repeated hundreds
thousands tens of thousands of times and
if you haven't noticed yet this is like
the perfect training for beating muzon
you repeat the routines which are in
fact the sun breathing forms until the
sun comes up by which time if you were
fighting muzon muzon will be burned by
the sun within this dance lies the key
to beating muzon including the fact that
the 13th form as we find out later is
connecting the 12 forms in a ring and
repeating them over and over again when
done right it's like the ultimate
unstoppable endless combo move back to
tanjuro being concerned about his dad
since he's worried about tanjuro's
health he says if it's hard for his dad
he will take his place starting next
year thus tundra offers to take over and
do the gruelling dance ritual however
surprisingly tangera's dad says there's
no need for the last few years despite
his illness he hasn't felt that the
dance was difficult imagine that not
feeling like it is difficult to dance
from sunset to sunrise non-stop that
would even be borderline impossible for
a healthy person and yet tanjuro's sick
dad can do it without difficulty at this
point he continues saying it's strange
he learned to dance from his dad when he
was younger healthier and stronger than
now yet he ran out of breath and found
it hard he thinks it's probably because
he made a lot of unnecessary movements
he emphasizes the importance of proper
breathing and control and making the
most efficient moves to exert the most
strength once he figured out how to do
that his head became clear and it was
much easier he explains that in the
beginning you must learn the moves and
sensibilities you open your five senses
become conscious of your own body down
to each and every blood vessel this
period is truly strenuous and you will
think that no matter how much you
struggle you will not be able to go
further however after you have learned
and absorbed many things you cut away
what is unnecessary you leave only what
is necessary in your movement and close
yourself off he says when people try to
listen closely they close their eyes and
similarly in this case you focus on what
is most necessary in the moment before
long you become able to open and close
the blood vessels and muscles throughout
your body as quickly and easily as
blinking and then you can open an
illuminated path when your head becomes
clear you begin to see the transparent
world however he insists that you only
reach this domain because you push
yourself to the limits of your strength
it's interesting they used the word
domain there the exact same word akasa
used so clearly tangero's dad had
reached this domain of supremacy and he
was able to maintain it if he wasn't
using it all the time then we can at
least assume he was using it from sunset
to sunrise and that's how he was able to
keep dancing without difficulty
considering that tundra only just
accesses the selfless state against
akaza and can't even maintain it for
long it's reasonable to assume that
tundra's that even sikh was stronger
than tangido even though tanjuro is
confirmed to be above hashira level at
this point this is an insane level of
strength reminiscent of yorichis that i
think few people expected this
non-swordsman to have and as if to
confirm to us that tanjuro was good at
fighting and not just dancing we then
get a scene of tundra's dad confronting
a giant bear this was just 10 days
before his dad died so he's doing all
this while very sick which is important
to keep in mind it's kind of like how
yurichi even as an old man was able to
fight like he was still in his prime
against upper moon 1 kokushibo even
while he was breathing his dying breath
from old age once people reach this
level it seems like they can fight like
they're in their prime right up to the
moment they die back to the bear and it
had already eaten someone on the next
mountain over thus out of caution they
put up ropes with bells so they would
hear it coming and have time to prepare
tanjuro woke up calmly told tundra to
follow him and they soon found
themselves face to face with this giant
bear it was unrealistically big like
bigger than any demon i can think of it
could just be partially the angle shown
or tundra's memories may exaggerate its
size a bit but it is massive and
absolutely towers over tundra's dad and
is way way wider a quick google search
tells me on the bigger end real bears
get to only about 8 to possibly 10 feet
long so this is some mythical creature
bear that tundra's dad is facing it's
like the god of the mountain version of
a bear tundra even says it was 9 shaku
an old japanese unit of measurement and
the viz translation tells me that one
shaku equals 2.72 meters that means this
bear is according to tanjuro about 24.5
meters tall or 80 feet imagine that this
is like a godzilla bear and this frail
skinny sick dude is about to confront it
calmly no less kid tundra is sweating
all over as he thinks about how this
bear had already eaten 6 people it was
still on the other side of the bell so
tanjuro could sense him before the bells
even rank tundra explains that his
father was ill but faced the bear with a
single axe they didn't even own a
hunting rifle not only was tundra
totally calm with not even a bead of
sweat on his face but he even took pity
on the giant bear he told the bear he's
sorry it's hungry but he will not let it
come any closer he won't show any mercy
to anyone who harms his family if the
bear doesn't obey his warning he will
steal its life again he's making it
clear it's nothing personal the bear
approaches anyway and we get a different
panel where the bear looks only like
it's about twice as big as the father on
page 11 of chapter 151 now it's unclear
if this is an inconsistency on the
mangaka's part like when she forgot that
tundra's arm was unusable anymore in
chapter 204 or if the point is that it
just looked bigger to kid tanjiro than
it actually was either way it was the
biggest bear you ever saw and it was
coming and tanjuro effortlessly defeated
it by taking its head in a fraction of a
second tundra was shocked at seeing the
bear's head as thick as a man's body
falling to the ground he says he
couldn't follow the attack but he thinks
his father made two cuts in the blink of
an eye otherwise it would have been
impossible to cut off the head with an
axe of that size tundra also noticed
that his father's scent didn't change
before and after severing the head there
was no fear or ill will in him no
fighting spirit he maintained his usual
calm throughout the process he was still
like a plant and thus clearly using the
selfless state which i truly feel like
he was always walking around in kind of
like how tundra learned to use total
concentration breathing all the time
instead of in short bursts only later
does tundra realize that his father was
giving him a lesson here of how to see
the transparent world he also told him
to never give up thinking things through
eventually he can break through any wall
with unceasing effort and then from this
memory tanjuro figures out how to
maintain access to the transparent world
and how to enter the selfless state
tundra explains that the transparent
world that his father taught him about
dramatically increased the speed with
which he could predict moves and evade
attacks furthermore we see how in this
state time passes slowly for tanjiro and
he is even able to avoid taking any
serious damage from akka's finisher move
that marked giu even calls inescapable
after it brings the water hashira to his
knees tendril goes on to slice off
akiza's head and even tells akasa he's
going to do it beforehand in this way he
shows it wasn't just some cheap trick or
that it wasn't luck he made sure aksa
was prepared and then proceeded to
outclass him tundra then gives in to
exhaustion and becomes practically
powerless until he takes some time to
recover but i wanted to point out the
power of the selfless state to
illustrate how strong his dad must have
been all the time since as i pointed out
it is suggested that he could maintain
this state at the very least from sunset
to sunrise during the dance of the fire
god ritual so am i saying that tanjuro a
dude who possibly had no training in
swordsmanship could have beaten upper
moon 3 akasa well yeah in my mind he was
definitely skilled enough the only thing
he was missing was a nichiren blade
because we know that non-nutrient
weapons can't actually finish off demons
however we've seen people like sanemy
use normal weapons to hold the demon off
until sunrise and beat them that way so
that was always a possibility for tundra
as well if he ever came across a demon
if you don't take my word for it though
and think i'm over hyping tanjuro take
tanjiro's own words during chapter 192
on page 11 tundra says himself i don't
have yorichi's or father's skill i don't
even know if i could stay alive until
dawn end quote not only is he speaking
of yorichi and tanjuro in the same
sentence in order to suggest how far
above him they both are he's also
commenting that he doesn't know if he
can last until dawn he knows that yorici
and his dad could last until dawn though
as he's watched his father do many times
during the dance ritual the implication
is that both yorichi and tanjuro could
maintain the selfless state in this
battle probably without much difficulty
but tanjiro as is pointed out multiple
times has trouble getting enough oxygen
and is too exhausted to maintain the
transparent world and the selfless state
in his case he has to just do the best
he can and rely on help from his
comrades although yurichi is
indisputably the peak of demon slaying
and the strongest demon slayer of all
time the story makes it clear that
tanjuro aka tanjiro's dad also reached a
high level that tundra himself has
perhaps glimpsed but hasn't yet fully
reached it's also suggested that tundra
was also a kind of more natural
successor for yurichi or more of a
chosen one than tanjiro because as
tanjiro pointed out before he heard his
dad was actually born with a faint mark
on his forehead while tanjiro only got
his after protecting his brother from a
falling portable heater on one occasion
and before i pointed out how it doesn't
really matter how tundra got it what
matters is that he did develop his mark
and he is a kind of chosen one in the
series as much as he wants to deny it
but in his defense it truly appears like
his father had more of the signs and
talent you would usually associate with
a chosen one than tanjiro himself after
all the chosen sun breather was supposed
to be born with a mark on his forehead
while tundra wasn't and his dad was the
reason tanjura's burn looking mark
didn't awaken like tangeros did in my
opinion is because he didn't actually
come into contact with demons it is only
after tanjuro undertakes the path of the
demon slayer that his mark eventually
evolves and starts to look more and more
like urichis i think the same thing
would have happened with tanjuro if his
parents and siblings were killed and he
joined the demon circle to beat muzon
and it's significant that tanjuro died
before the family was attacked by muzon
because tanjuro was arguably skilled
enough to make a difference or at least
complicate muzon's attack on the family
we can't say for sure what would have
happened especially since tanjuro didn't
have a nichiren blade as far as we know
but i feel like he would have at least
been able to distract muzon long enough
for more family members to escape it
definitely seems like he had the speed
for that so if we compare tundra to
yorichi or even to his own father he
wasn't really a genius and doesn't give
off chosen one vibes as hard which is
refreshing about this story it doesn't
have to be a series like naruto where
naruto surpasses that and everyone else
tanjo could just do his best get help
from others and accomplish his goals
without reaching his father's level of
mastery and definitely without reaching
yurichi's level of mastery i hope i've
shown and proven how overpowered tundra
actually was in this video the reason he
is easy to overlook is that a he died
before the story begins and before he
confronted any demons and b because he
as far as we know never actually got a
nitrogen blade and demon slayer training
however if we pay close attention to the
story and take note of what tundra can
accomplish when he glimpses the power
his father could maintain then it's
clear to see how overpowered he actually
was yes he probably could have benefited
from a nitrogen blade and swordsmanship
training but he didn't have the need for
either in his lifetime and even without
training we saw what he could do with a
tiny axe so i bet he wouldn't have much
trouble adjusting to the sword if he was
given the chance i'd go so far as to say
that tundra's dad is the closest anyone
got to yorichi's level of skill and it's
a shame we didn't get to see his skills
transferred over to demon fights but it
was necessary for the story since
tanjiro wouldn't have been able to
improve and struggle if his father
became the sun hoshida and just wrecked
all the demons for him so to conclude
tundra's dad was so strong he had to be
killed off before the demon fighting
arrived so that tanjiro would be forced
to grow into his full potential but also
keep in mind although it was suggested
that tanjuro was naturally more talented
in sun breathing than tanjiro he was
also way older and only during the last
few years of his life had the sunset to
sunrise dancing become more or less easy
for him tundra on the other hand is only
16 when the story ends despite
everything he's accomplished already and
it's very likely that he'll be just as
good at performing the dance and
maintaining the selfless state as his
father was given enough time and that is
it for this one hope you enjoyed this
deep dive into tanjuro aka tanjiro's dad
his skill and his unrealized but massive
potential as a demon slayer if you did
enjoy this video and want to keep them
coming you know what to do chill the
demonstration and smash that like button
with no mercy remember smashing that
like button is strongest demon slayer
energy and passing his scared moose on
energy so choose wisely make tundra's
dad proud if you have it make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates
including updates about the very very
hype new seasons and while you wait for
the next video to drop or the next
season even feel free to check out my
huge and growing demonstrator playlist
that includes videos in all the demon
moons hashira why everyone is afraid of
tanjiro yurichi's full story and much
more link to that is in the description
and until next time see ya space cowboys